i'm kind of drawn to the unknown a
little bit i just try to do things i
don't know how to do you know it's a
continued education just kind of trying
to embrace something and going i'm not
sure i can do that you know and it
doesn't mean i'll do anything i haven't
done before but you know there has to be
some sense of
you can get underneath it and find
the kind of steering wheel
why i mean you have to ask answer the
question why do you have to tell this
story ultimately when you
talk directly to artists you can start
to bring them into hey this is the scene
here's the character here's what he's
saying he's saying that but he's really
lying but right after he says that he's
he's like did that work you know and and
there's all that sort of unknowing stuff
that happens and what's he feeling when
it comes to the scene where did we come
from so everybody who worked on this
film
um
at that point and there were
150 talented artists i think they all
knew
the entire movie and where it fit and
where the character was going and you
know where is my scene fit into
everything else and
you know what's rango feeling at this
moment or what spoons or waffles or
these other characters what are they
about what is their you know
where they coming from and where they
going
you direct animators like you direct
actors i think you know i mean they are
you know there's casting involved when
you hand pick
you know your team and um
and they are you know they're
conjuring a performance so
you have to there's no you can't be
mechanical you know at some point you
know
uh
they're there at three in the morning
working on frame 272
and you know
and i want them to go oh you know i
should try this
you know this other thing or this twitch
or this nervous
flicker or something you know you kind
of throw
detail at something until it becomes
sentient i mean it's like a sample rate
issue it starts out
not that different than sort of hairy
house and clay even no it's on a
computer and you just start
you know going through frame by frame
and saying there should be a little
you know muscle spasm under the eye one
heat and a twitch here and a
and a flicker there and a moment of
doubt and it's really kind of trying to
get you know nuance in there until
at some point it starts to
become i would say a kind of particular
reality not you know not a sense
not not a reality because we don't have
squid-faced characters walking down the
street every day so you're kind of going
in with a sort of theatrical reality but
and then um
you know i just i i've always been
fascinated with that sense of um
like a dream logic like it doesn't make
any sense but you kind of go with it and
i think that that's um
that's that's where david jones lies and
your dreams
i like films that feel like they could
go off the rails at any moment you know
they're sort of
you don't quite trust them
and so we tried to embrace that and
particularly in a in a format that you
know
lends itself to perfection so easily i
mean everything is on a computer
everything is kind of
frontal lobe and conceived and plotted
and there's nothing
really intuitive in the process because
nothing's real time so you
you're constantly
fabricating anomaly and and
and also in you know even a story real
phase in the beginning just embracing
concepts that
you know might be um you're not quite
sure they're gonna work but you know
they're even if they fail they'll be
kind of wonderful disasters
did you see that what do you think doc